for me I work on multiple different  projects for different clients at the  same time there are other consultancies  where you are on one project for a set  number of months  just to add in here now from the mbb  perspective here in the first years you  will always like 99 of the times you  will be dedicated to one project you  will not work at different projects in  parallel this only starts once you are a  senior project lead once you want to  make the transition to become a junior  partner this is then when you start  maybe leading and being responsible for  two or three projects in parallel but  this is now a step in the career that is  many years down the line